I worked for the now defunct retailer
Circuit City for five years really yeah
selling extended services they pay very
well but I don't know when you work very
well in the commission I got laid off
when they went from commission to hourly
yeah the people who were making too many
commissions they didn't want to pay a
salary they laid us off check this out
okay so let me let me see if what year
was it you work in a Circuit City it
ended in 2003 so it would have been like
the era by the way can you tell
everybody how much a good salesperson at
Circuit City was making
well if you remember because I I I'm
willing to say this I worked part-time
because I was like starting College
check this out 30 hours a week and I was
making 75 000. that's insane yeah at
Circuit City yeah okay they realized it
was insane and they're like we're not
paying these people
because that's why they went out of
business right the model was working you
guys were doing your part
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]